why did that why did the uh you guys
remember on the podcast when we had
miranda cosgrove and i was like what's
your favorite curse word and she's like
probably fuck why did that become viral
i
thi for the first time in my life feel
old because i do not understand tick
tock i understand a video that shows me
how to make quick tater tots or how to
you know whatever i i posted a video
where i'm cutting a cake with dental
floss millions of years i get that
because it's like little things like
that i'm like yes i'm gonna send this to
my friends why is sound goes viral i i
don't
know the one i i downloaded tic tac for
one second though because i got obsessed
with this woman who feeds her dogs raw
meat she feeds them like raw duck heads
and like pig uteruses
and i go oh okay i can kind of get why
oh my god i'm obsessed with watching
this woman put a full like rooster's
penis in a dog's mouth
and then everything out my understanding
falls like so i was just watching it for
porn yeah i was jerking off to watching
a
dog sucking a cat's dick and then anyway
what were you talking about
i don't know i don't under
and then you know because i'm just
curious if it's in because when
you're on snl and you're and you're
deciding what sketches to come up with
and what's going to be popular it's like
is the conversation like oh hey this was
big on tick tock we should spoof it on
the show
you know like is that something that now
is
obviously legitimate in a platform to
where you guys incorporate it in because
you're like this is obviously relevant
i like
my sketch writing process is almost like
what is something we can make that will
will
get
a sued to show on television
like i'm like i feel like i'm like
antiviral
like it's like
everything i come up with is like oh god
[Laughter]
what's your favorite thing so far that
you've that hasn't gone on yet that has
we've written like a bunch of like
really disgusting sketches
that are
haven't made it onto the show just
because i like fucked it up and like i'm
learning how to do the show right but
they are like letting me try
some stuff oh my god
funny all of a sudden when did that
start okay good thank god they're really
annoying oh good uh
i'm gonna ask some questions from the
internet oh ooh
you've talked a lot about your snl
edition i bet right
no i don't know how did you do i don't
think so
i couldn't find it just saying you just
did stand up
in front of lauren or you did it at a
club and he came and saw you i did jfl
mm-hmm and i i did what was the pandemic
jfl um
just for left comedy festival should i
explain it no i mean yeah google it guys
so i just did and it was the pandemic
version of jfl so it was just a show
dynasty typewriter wow 10 minutes from
my house didn't have to think about it
and they filmed it and he saw it or he
was just there i think they i don't know
who was there
i just walked in did something
did have seven minutes of comedy didn't
have to fly to montreal
then you just get a call
and then they like have you do like the
whole like audition process after that
yeah and so you went to new york and
just did
just stand up again god bless in front
of lauren yes
god bless just the same set
it's like
you know
yeah
i like because i i do not have a
background in like characters and sketch
and anything like that
what is there any celebrity impressions
that are like you're thinking about
am i gonna do a really good cartman
oh i can't do an impression i can't do
anything you pro but you probably have
some that you'll just stumble on i'm
sure if like a gun was put to my head i
could do an impression of someone
getting shot yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]